Matt you asked the question can we go
skateboarding on the Moon or Mars or
this be more of a a hoverboard scenario
well both the Moon and Mars have a
weaker surface gravity than the earth
does so you don't weigh as much on the
Moon or Mars as you do here but there
still is enough gravity to stick you to
the surface so I think you could
actually sting on your board and keep it
down you probably wouldn't accelerate as
fast as you do here on earth so for
example on earth you'd be going down a
hill picking up speed on the Moon and
Mars the gravity is weaker so you
wouldn't be picking up as much speed so
in fact skateboarding might be a little
bit dull on the Moon and Mars the good
thing is that if you fall over
you also don't fall with the same force
you would but from the gravity of the
earth so you probably be a bit safer but
the question actually kind of has got me
thinking about what sort of sports you
could do on some of the worlds in our
solar system that you just could not do
here at all and there are several places
in the solar system that have relatively
low surface gravity the gravity isn't as
strong as here on the surface of the
earth but they have thick atmospheres
there's a moon called Titan that orbits
Saturn and Titan is a really big object
I mean physically it's actually not that
much smaller than the planet Mars
Titans gravity isn't as strong as
Earth's but the atmosphere is actually
thicker there's actually a little more
air pressure on Titan than there is here
on earth it's a very different sort of
air there's no oxygen it's actually
mostly nitrogen a little bit of carbon
dioxide so you couldn't breathe you'd
have to bring a breathing apparatus and
it's also very cold it's about 300
degrees below zero but if you had a
really SuperDuper parka and you got a
breathing apparatus you could actually
survive on the surface of Titan there's
air pressure with air pressure and low
gravity you could actually strap large
wings to your arms I mean imagine wings
made of some wonderful flexible metal
and maybe like titanium and if you
jumped off a cliff you could fly you
could actually start flapping your wings
and actually getting lift and you could
fly just yourself jumping off a cliff on
Titan and flying around in that thicker
atmosphere and there are other places
where you have relatively low gravity
but giant cliffs for example there's a
moon of Uranus called Miranda and
Miranda has cliffs that are many miles
high so you can jump off a cliff and
fall very slowly and very gently down to
the bottom if you think about the the
idea of feather falling that's something
from Dungeons and Dragons you can fall
very care
fully and not actually hurt yourself
there might be sport on Miranda like
skydiving but you don't need a parachute
you just float down very gently and land
[Music]